vingt-quatre heures après l'annonce à
belfort les trois syndicats sont
ensemble sous tes l'union pour dénoncer
la suppression envisagée de 1000 postes
dans ses usines
ils en appellent aujourd'hui à l'état
pour faire pression sur general electric
on est en train de détruire comment dire
une histoire industrielle de 140 ans on
est en train de détruire l'avenir de
l'industrie en france
si le gouvernement n'est pas capable de
se positionner par rapport à ça mais il
pour ce faire toutes les promesses sur
les sol et sur l'emploi et qui vont
faire le maximum s'ils n'agissent pas
maintenant quand est ce qu'ils vont agir
pour l'emploi en france
des suppressions d'emplois annoncées qui
cachent selon eux un plan de
délocalisation massive de la production
engagé par general electric le groupe
reconnaît que la turbine à gaz a de
l'avenir
jusqu'à 2 jusqu'en 2040 au mois ils font
des projections jusqu'en 2040
donc après venir dire que c'est le
marché venir mettre les déficits
importants sur le dos des salariés de
belfort c'est juste inadmissible
à la veille du week-end de l'ascension
les ouvriers ne sont pas tous présents
sur ce site de belfort
mais les syndicalistes s'organise déjà
ils promettent aujourd'hui des actions
d'envergure la semaine prochaine en tout
cas il ya une chose qui est sûre âgées
un peu d'émotion mais il ya une chose
qui est sûre c'est qu'on va se battre ça
c'est sûr et certain j'ai fait le tour
un peu des ateliers des bureaux et les
gens sont prêts à se mobiliser pour
conserver leur emploi
de son côté le gouvernement assure
suivre le dossier general electric avec
vigilance
bruno le maire le ministre de l'économie
se rendra d'ailleurs à belfort la
semaine prochaine pour rencontrer les
salariés
[Musique]